leads right so all the time you hear
about people I've got an interview here
or I've been offered a job here but I'm
not taking it I have this Excel
spreadsheet where I'm like okay this
business have been hiring loads and
every time I get a lead I write that
lead down on my Excel spreadsheet and
then I organize that A to Z so it might
be the company 10 times and I'm like oh
Dave heart went to hire 10 times within
the last year they're someone that I
want to go after whereas I might have
only got one lead for another company
and that might then equate to they're
actually not hiring that much so they're
not going to be a huge Target and then
once you've got that it's all about the
touch points so how frequently are you
contacting them and then what approach
does that look like so once you know
that agency spend how often they're
hiring what the roles are that they're
hiring for it's then all about the
approach
[Music]